as Europeans face skyrocketing energy  bills the European Parliament is backing  calls for the EU to shoulder the burden  of the cost mep's welcomed commission  proposals to reduce bills by  redistributing excessive profits made by  energy companies but said it must go  further  parliaments called for better support  for the most vulnerable consumers and  businesses  members want EU countries to make sure  Europeans are not faced with evictions  and that their basic needs like  affordable food Heating and transport  are met  these measures should be part of a  longer-term strategy of investing in  renewable energy other measures to face  the energy crisis include making  buildings energy efficient across the EU  Parliament also condemned moscow's  weaponization of energy supplies and  reaffirmed its support for Ukraine in  the face of Russia's invasion  [Music]